diesen frühling bekannte der us
amerikanische olympiasieger bruce jenner
ich bin eine frau und feierte
ausgeliehen einen neuanfang inszeniert
von der star fotografin annie leibovitz
sechs tage später erklärte die
amerikanische bürgerrechtsaktivisten
rangelow lisa ich identifiziere mich als
schwarz obwohl ihre eltern offenlegten
dass sie als weiße geboren wurde
menschen wechseln also nicht nur beruf
wohnort oder partnerin
sie wechseln auch ihr geschlecht oder
ihre hautfarbe
doch wie geht das und können wir uns
wirklich ganz neuer finden hautfarbe
inklusive darüber diskutiere ich heute
mit der sozial anthropologin serie a
dank war die zur frage der sexuellen
identität arbeitet uns dem historiker
valentin groebner der sich unter anderem
mit der geschichte der hautfarbe
auseinandersetzt
herzlich willkommen der fall rachel
corrie sanders auf eine frau die
jahrzehnte lang mit der identität einer
auf amerikanerin lebt und dann als weiße
geoutet wird von ihren eltern in den usa
das für viel wirbel gesorgt frau wanka
sie haben eine weile lang in den usa
gelebt können sie sich diesen wirbel
erklären
ja wobei ich sagen muss ich habe mich
eigentlich auch erst mal gefragt weshalb
dieser werbe in wessen interesse ist
dass das ausgerechnet zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt diese geschichte so viel von
medien ins zentrum gerückt wird wer
profitiert davon und ich bin ich ein
bisschen zum schluss gekommen dass es
eigentlich darum geht gewisse andere
abzulenken von anderen themen die jetzt
eben aufs tablett kommen also
polizeigewalt gegen schwarze oder der
ganze strukturellen rassismus dass das
eigentlich ein bisschen es wurde auch
von der rechtskonservativen ecke diese
ganze entlarvung dieser person und dann
das ganze die schadenfreude darüber und
so ein bisschen das sagen ja es ist
sogar attraktiv schwarz sein was habt
ihr denn für ein problem die man ja sie
profitieren ja nur davon
und das hat mich ehrlich vor allem
irritiert gleichzeitig gab es aber schon
auch die kritik von personen die jetzt
für die afro amerikaner sprechen die
gesagt haben oder cloud einer unsere
identität und man kann eigentlich nicht
eine identität programmieren
ohne den entsprechenden
erfahrungshintergrund zu haben weil
welche rolle ich sage ich natürlich auf
weißes mädchen aufgewachsen habe also
dadurch die diskriminierung nicht
erfahren
ja also sie hat eigentlich sie
profitiert von dem privileg also
überhaupt wählen zu können was sie sein
möchte das ist ja ein privileg und das
hat viel damit mit der spezifischen
geschichte von rasse auch zu tun in den
usa also zum beispiel diese one drop
ruhl die bis in die 80er jahre
eigentlich relevant war also das
bedeutet dass man sobald man einen
tropfen schwarzes blut hat als schwarz
gilt und von daher können eigentlich
also muss man das jemand überhaupt nicht
mehr ansehen das er afrikanisches erbe
hat irgendwo umgekehrt also diese
grenzziehung zwischen schwarz und weiß
brunner nicht darauf dass die weisheit
rein gehalten werden will und alles
andere was quasi kontaminiert ist dass
es außer hat das ist dann einfach
schwarz und dadurch wird diese kategorie
schwarz als sehr porös und umgekehrt
das also dieser idee dass man dann
wechseln kann das funktioniert nur in
der einen richtung das zeigt sich auch
in diesem fall herr grimm nach kann man
sich die hautfarbe ding einfach
aussuchen
[Musik]
ich bin mir da nicht sicher aber das was
jeweils als hautfarbe eine kollektive
guard kategorie ist ist alles andere als
fest
die europäer haben vor 500 jahren nicht
den eindruck gehabt dass sie selber weiß
sind
ich frage mich auch ob die ob diese
extreme gegenüberstellung weiß schwarz
oder ja viel eher dass es nichts
dazwischen gibt nicht eine sehr
us-amerikanische besonderheit ist man
könnte sich ja fragen ob eine solche
geschichte wie die
die gerade erzählt haben in brasilien
oder indien oder in der karibik alles
länder wo die zugehörigkeit zu
hautfarben durchaus eine große rolle
spielt so möglich wäre weil es gibt ja
offenbar nichts dazwischen und die ja
auch eine vergangenheit haben als
starten indem die sklaverei eine große
rolle gespielt haben
also insofern würde waren erwarten dass
die trennung die rassentrennung auch
entsprechende spuren hinterlassen hat
ich werde das gefühl nicht los dass das
dass da immer von von großen
vermeintlich festen historischen
kategorien gesprochen wird wir sind weiß
weil wir immer schon weiß waren die
reinheit die er in dem fall die reinheit
der vorfahren ist die frau dank war
angesprochen hat in dem moment wo man in
die geschichte schaut stellt man fest
die europäer haben sich selber nicht als
weiß bezeichnet und hautfarben sind aus
in der hinsicht als feste kategorien die
man vererbt als rasse eigentlich eine
erfindung der moderne der aufklärung
ironischerweise vor herz das so nicht
gegeben die leute haben sich selber ganz
anders beschrieben
aber was heißt das wenn ich habe vorher
hat es das nicht gegeben es gibt keine
texte in denen personen als schwarz
gezeichnet werden das stimmt ja nicht
ganz geht zb den schwarzen ohren kennt
man aus der ikonographie aus der
ikonographie der berner [ __ ]
gesellschaft eine patriotische feine
leute gesellschaft der die sich selber
den monats abzeichen gibt es gibt
natürlich das bild des männlichen
schwarzen als adeliges abzeichen in ganz
europa seit dem 11 12 jahrhundert
es gibt die präsenz von schwarzen aber
das wird es gibt die die figur des
äthiopiers des afrikaners das wird aber
nicht unbedingt mit rasse und es wird
auch nicht unbedingt mit sklaverei in
verbindung gebracht sondern
das ist das sind mythische abstammung
geschichten die europäer selbst
begreifen ihre eigenen körper nicht als
weiß betrag der italienische
humanistische dichter sagt von sich
selbst ich bin genau in der mitte
zwischen weiß und schmerzlich ich habe
die ideale hautfarbe gehabt in meiner
jugend und das ist gängig das heißt das
ist ein altes modell von vom körper
farben gerne die in der die frauen immer
heller sind als die männer und die
männer sind entweder rot oder dunkel und
die ärzte des 13 15 bis 17 jahrhundert
waren davon überzeugt dass sich diese
komplexe das individuelle verhältnis der
körpersäfte durch klima durch alter
durch durch ernährung im lauf des
eigenen lebens ändert deswegen war dann
genau wie wir ja auch andere aufgaben
haben im februar oder ende august also
die geschichte der hautfarbe zeigt wenn
ich das richtig verstehe dass erst im
grunde genommen durch die sklaverei
durch den ganzen imperialismus diese
hautfarben konnotation auch einherging
mit einer abwertung wenn ich das
bestätigen franke ich denke schon es hat
mit der aufklärung und mit dem
kolonialismus auf alle fälle noch eine
weitere dimension gekriegt weil es ja da
wirklich darum gegen unterdrückung
verhältnisse zu rechtfertigen also
rassen gibt es ja eigentlich nicht wir
sind eine menschen rasse und dass dieses
konstrukt dazu gedient hat ein
einerseits ein gegenbild zu schaffen um
zu sagen weil weil die anders sind kann
man sie auch anders behandeln so ganz
einfach ausgedrückt und andererseits
also der transatlantischen sklavenhandel
ist eigentlich ist ein beispiel davon
aber die ganze kolonialgeschichte die
art und weise wie man eine wahl
westlicher überlegenheit die der
westlichen überlegenheit verbreitet hat
dass das war eine wechselwirkung also es
ging darum den anderen konz zu
konstruieren aber es ging vor allem auch
darum das weiße subjekt zu konstruieren
und eben diese grenzen zu ziehen
und zu sagen wir sind modern wir sind
aufgeklärt wir sind egalitär und die
anderen sind anders und da kommt
eigentlich gar nicht so sehr daran
darauf an ob das jetzt das bild des
edlen [ __ ] war oder ob das das bild
des schmutzigen und mit pech
assoziierten schwarzen war also es geht
da vor allem weil diese bilder das sind
stereotypisierung 'nen das sind
fremdbilder dienen letztlich beide dazu
diese dieses dieser überlegenheit zu
markieren oder zu rechtfertigen
gehen wir zurück in die heutige zeit
sprechen wir über eine person die oft in
diesem kontext genommen nämlich über
michael jackson michael jackson war ja
ein popstar der sehr oft mit der frage
konfrontiert wurde was es für ihn denn
eigentlich heißt schwarz zu sein und ob
er sich schämt schwarz zu sein weil er
mir und mir eben weiß wurde und es gibt
ein interview von oprah winfrey von 1993
dazu interviewt auf seiner neverland
ranch und in diesem interview betont
michael jackson dass er sehr stolz
darauf sei schwarz zu sein
und er stellt auch die frage warum ist
eigentlich so ist dass wir nicht
personen dafür kritisieren die weiß sind
die sich in der sonne bräunen und diesen
ausschnitt möchte ich gerne mit ihnen
ansehen
wanka stimmt der vergleich von michael
jackson ja finde ich schon legitim weil
haut gleich ein paar schwarzen wieder
immer pathologisiert und als ein weiß
sein wollen ich sage nicht es hat nichts
mit wein zu tun aber es ist zum teil
auch eine alltagspraxis also es ist in
unterschiedlichen kontexten wird das
unterschiedlich gemacht aber so wie es
hier leute gibt die sagen ich fühle mich
einfach besser wenn ich in den spiegel
sehe und ich bin gebräunt ich war an der
sonne egal ob das auch krebserregend ist
sich in die sonne zu legen
ich fühle mich einfach besser und
dasselbe narrativ gibt es eben auch bei
frauen die sagen ja ich muss mir diese
creme morgens auftragen
ich weiß es ist ungesund aber irgendwie
dass das das steht mir einfach ich kann
bessere farben tragen also im
ghanaischen kontext kommt es häufig so
sie kommen aus oder ihr vater kommt aus
ghana die haben auch lange in ghana
gearbeitet deswegen ja wenn die ja das
aber ich meine dem bleaching gibt es in
indien gibt es überall und es ist ein
universelles phänomen und das hat mit
weißer überlegenheit zu tun
es ist auch erwiesen im us
amerikanischen kontext dass ihr helle
die komplexen also die die schattierung
desto besser desto mehr lohn desto
bessere jobchancen also selbst trotz
dieser one drop ruhl es gibt diese
offenbar diese abstufung und und das
werden wir so die ice trasse sehr stark
mit klasse gekoppelt es wird mit
sozialer mobilität assoziiert also es
gibt oder zum beispiel im
südafrikanischen kontext ist es ist das
war das auch eine praxis von leuten die
als schwarz kategorisiert waren um sich
gewisse vorteile zu verschaffen also ich
will daran gar nicht rütteln
aber dennoch muss man sich auch immer
vor augen halten offenbar wenn zwei
dasselbe tun ist es nicht dasselbe und
ich mein michael jackson ist natürlich
schon ein fall für sich da gibt es viele
fragen viele
ja da wird über die auch pathologisiert
aus verschiedenen gründen aber was man
schon auch sagen muss allgemein
wenn bei schwarzen künstlern sie sind
immer schwarze künstler wenn sie
irgendwie einfach mal künstler sein
wollen ohne immer auf ihre hautfarbe
also irgendwie ein oder auf ihre
herkunft jetzt im europäischen kontext
vielleicht mehr man wird immer diese
rückbezug immer hergestellt man muss
etwas über die hautfarbe aus sagt man
ist ein repräsentant eine repräsentantin
einer bestimmten gruppe und um das
abzulehnen ablebens kann es ist ganz
schwierig das ist ganz profi lanig alles
was man macht wird wieder darauf
zurückgeführt weil es ist das
unbeschriebene papier sozusagen
und es war ja wahnsinnig spannend andy
warhol über seine hautfarbe zu
interviewen und über seine weißen haare
ist aber interessanterweise nicht
gemacht worden
aber ich frage mich ob man das erläutern
warum für mich ich finde das
interessante an michael jackson die
plastizität seines gesichts die die
formen die diese nase zwischendurch
angriff angenommen hat da fand ich als
betrachter in den in den durch die
medien extrem interessant hier geht es
ja glaube ich um eine person also um die
art und weise wie jemand sich selbst in
den medien darstellt der verwandelt sich
in eine maske und die vorstellung dass
das dass man das äußere einer person
dass der sich dafür verteidigen muss für
das was er ist
er tritt natürlich selber in der rolle
von als michael jackson auf dass das was
wir da sehen ist das produkt der
spezifischen form des fernsehinterviews
und hat mit dem wirklichen michael
jackson was da wirklich tut oder macht
natürlich relativ wenig zu tun es ist
ein kunstprodukt das in der derjenige
als die maske seiner selbst auftritt für
einen popstar immer der fall ist dass
sich auch in seinen konzerten der fall
in den interviews generell die ergibt
liegt ja auf der hand wenn man ein
popstar ist dass man ein stück weit zur
kunstfigur irrt
[Musik]
deswegen habe ich vorher andy warhol ins
spiel gebracht jemand der als künstler
auftritt und der diese art von selbst
zelebrierung als man könnte es praktisch
sagen super weiß ja selbst auch macht
hier geht es aber um medienformate es
geht nicht um wirkliche personen was die
wirkliche person tut oder lässt kann man
aufgrund der medien sozusagen dieses
spiegelbild in den elektronischen medien
glaube ich nur relativ schwer
aber was ja wahrscheinlich die der
diskussionspunkt war bei michael jackson
ist dass man von ihm erwartet hat dass
er sich einsetzt für die afrikanische
community dass er sich einsetzt gegen
rassismus wasser ja auch getan habe zum
teil
man habe es ihm übelgenommen dass man
den eindruck hatte er verleugnet seine
schwarze hautfarbe und genau dieses
moment hat ja auch eine geschichte es
gibt da die geschichte des so genannten
ratings also dass das wechseln der
hautfarbe und der diskriminierung zu
entgehen man muss auch sagen in ganzen
kontexten ist das vollkommen legitim das
zu tun man kann das bestens
nachvollziehen es gab immer wieder
menschen die versucht haben dadurch dass
sie sich aus besonders weiß gegeben
haben versucht haben ihre hautfarbe zu
verändern
diskriminierung zu entgehen und dass
umgekehrt bescheid nicht so sehr auf der
hand zu liegen dass sich bräunen weil
man sozusagen dann nicht direkt schon
auf privilegien verzichten müsste ich
bin ich nicht sicher ob ich die frage
verstanden habe aber wenn sie damit
nochmals auf der liester zurückkommen
und in die kritik die sie von der linken
seite bekommen hat muss man natürlich
sagen dass es gibt also erstens hatte
sich auch profiliert als schwarze sie
war ja da nicht einfach irgendwie im
hintergrund sondern sie hat gewisse
positionen gehabt sie sind und damit
auch symbolische ressourcen auch zum
teil ökonomisch aber ich denke es ging
vor allem um die symbolik und sie hat
andere belehrt was richtiges schwarz
sein sein soll wie das aussehen soll
das war ein problem und dann gibt es
auch noch die ganze geschichte von
der aneignung also von der
ausbeuterischen aneignung von
errungenschaften die eigentlich einen
schwarzen widerstands tradition
entstanden und was ich also stonewall
ist ein beispiel das wäre jetzt heute
zelebriert das war 1969 die aufstände in
new york als eigentlich beginn der
schulen und lesbenbewegung und zwar der
weißen schulen und lesbenbewegung obwohl
stonewall nachweislich von schwarzen
trans frauen von people of colour also
von nicht weißen menschen die da sehr
zentral waren und das wird aus der
geschichte heraus geschrieben oder das
auch überhaupt die leiste schule
bewegung sehr viel von der schwarzen
bürgerrechtsbewegung sich abgeguckt hat
es ist ja nicht legitim
also dass das dass der vorwurf gegen sie
auch aus dieser ecke oder aus dieser
frustration kommt aus dieser aneignung
ja das ist dass es die dass es diese
möglichkeit gibt oder dass es immer
wieder geschehen ist in der geschichte
und der andere vorwurf ist natürlich die
maskerade also dass das plug facing das
karikieren von als plaque facing ist
diese praxis die es von
schauspielerinnen und schauspielern sich
schwarze farbe ins gesicht zu streichen
sich ein akzent zuzulegen
in der schweiz ist der frau steinecker
ein beispiel die dass auch schon am
schweizer fernsehen dass das ist eine
praxis die übertreibung und damit der
reduzierung auf die hautfarbe und das
ist er auch wieder eine geschichte hat
kenia im theater in der komik und
verband damit kann man in den usa keine
karriere machen also dass das ist seit
den 60er jahren ist es eigentlich
verpönt und rachel du lisa indem sie
indem sie gewisse an gewissen schwarzen
style zelebriert ist also kann man ihr
vorwerfen dass sie genau das machen dass
sie eine stereotypisierung vornimmt also
dass das jetzt schwarz sein bedeutet ja
was ist jetzt wenn ich nicht so ein
akzent habe dass sie mir ja ein beispiel
an einen ganz interessanten moment ob es
dort schwarz sein gibt genauso wie es
eben die frage gibt im falle von bruce
jenner jetzt eben kein genie gibt es
darf
frau sein weil er nicht der ministerin
hingegangen sind und gesagt haben moment
man kann sich hier nicht einfach
plötzlich aus frau verkaufen und das
gefühl haben mit ein bisschen make-up
großen dekolleté und lackierten
fingernägeln ist man dann frau oder ist
frau dann frau und es scheint so wie ein
kern des frauseins zu geben ist das so
in der identität gibt es einen kern von
frau sein mannsein schwarz sein weiß
sein oder ist es einfach eine ganz
normale menschliche sehnsucht
ich hab auch wer mit dem begriff
identität identität ist ist so ein
zungen löser das ist gar kein wort das
ist ein luftsprung bon ein klebstoff mit
dem die leute über selbst und fremd
definition entsprechen
eigentlich gibt es so etwas wie die
identität nicht weil damit werden
es gibt verschiedene bedeutungen die an
dem begriff gehängt werden
die sind sehr unterschiedlich erstes mal
die identität dass ich behaupte ich
mache eine aussage über mich in der
ersten person dann ist identität eine
zuschreibung frau blaschke eine typische
philosophin und ziemlich gerne wissen
was sie damit noch effizienter und
drittens ist also ist identität wird als
kollektiv bezeichnung verwendet
klöckner ein typischer österreicher wir
die österreich hat das ist unsere
identität
das sind aber drei verschiedene dinge
das sind auch drei verschiedene sprech
situationen und der begriff identität
tut so als sei das ein als sei das ein
und dieselbe sache also ich glaube dass
identität nichts ist was man hat sondern
etwas was man von anderen bekommt oder
von anderen zugeschrieben bekommt und
wenn in dem fall ist die die jeweilige
bedeutungs polizei gibt die sagt wir
sagen was echtes schwarz sein ist im
gegensatz zu falschen schwarz sein oder
wir sagen
was echtes frau sein ist im gegensatz zu
falschen frau sein wird immer von
identität gesprochen
natürlich ist das etwas ich glaube ich
verstehe ganz genau was sie meinen
finger dieses konzept auch attraktiv
gleichzeitig glaube ich aber dass wir
genau umgekehrt denken in verschiedenen
kontexten also nehmen wir noch einmal
bruce jenner der stellt sich hin und
sagt ich bin im falschen körper geboren
ich sehe aus wie ein mann ich bin aber
eigentlich eine frau und es geht nicht
um eine geschlechtsumwandlung es geht um
eine geschlechtsanpassung das ist die
idee vertrauens menschen genau gleich
alisa die sagt ich bin zwar ausweise
geboren
aber eigentlich bin ich schwarz und ich
habe eine anpassung gemacht und ich
bleibe auch schwarz auch wenn ich mir
noch tausendmal sagt deine eltern sind
aber weiß also es geht genau und diese
idee eines inneren kerns oder ich finde
man muss schon unterscheiden zwischen
diesen beiden kategorien race & channel
und es gibt eine große gemeinsamkeit
gibt es sind beides kategorie sie
kategorien welche differenzen natur
alisa und sagen und um dadurch soziale
ungleichheit kreieren also es gibt
männer und frauen es gibt schwarze und
weiße aber es gibt gewisse unterschiede
und die sind eben wesentlich da muss ich
es aber ein bisschen ausholen
vielleicht müssen wir dazwischen noch
schieben um zu verstehen warum jetzt
darüber zu sprechen dass im kontext der
debatte und alisa zum ersten mal dieser
begriff des krans race auf thomas
manhart auf twitter den haar stark
translation kreiert und damit genau das
gemeint dass es so wies transgender gibt
menschen die das geschlecht sich in
einem anderen geschlecht geboren fühlen
aus was sie sind biologisch ist auch
menschen gibt die in einer anderen
hautfarbe sich fühlen
auf was sie optisch sind einfach auf
kleine clown lolli mehr und als andere
klammerten also die trans menschen gibt
es ja nicht es hat trans bedeutet ja
nicht ich will mein geschlecht anpassen
ich will jetzt möglichst perfekten body
des geschlechtes dass mir zur geburt
nicht zugeordnet wurde es gibt ganz
viele verständnis von trans und
transgender kann auch heißen genau diese
priorität
auf brechen zu wollen und auch zu sagen
es gibt geschlechter vielfalt es gibt
männlich und es gibt nicht nur männlich
und weiblich es gibt auch alles
dazwischen
es gibt eigentlich soviel geschlechter
wie es menschen gibt und diese arbeit
oder transgender machen eigentlich diese
arbeit und zum beispiel eine eine frau
mit bartwuchs sie sich diesen bart nicht
abschneidet die macht diese arbeit dass
das ist eine art das aufzudecken weil es
ja so eine verschleierung gibt oder an
ein mann mit schlafen großen brüsten der
keine hormone nimmt und nicht ins ins
studio ins fitnessstudio rennt da zeigt
sich dass auf diese arbeit muss gemacht
werden um das zu die sichtbar zu machen
jetzt bei race ist es aber so dass das
ist relativ offensichtlich oder dass es
als erstes wurde das längstens
debattiert rasse gibt es ja biologisch
nicht wir haben dieselben blutgruppen
wir haben dieselben organe das also ein
biologisches argument kann man ja gar
nicht machen und dazu kommt dieser
kleinen aber bedeutenden unterschied
zwischen diesen beiden kategorien dass
bei rasse versuchen also gesicht das ist
ja nicht nur hautfarbe es ist auch
phänotyp diese dinge rasen vorm hat und
so weiter das ist relativ schwer zu
verstecken dass es da ein spektrum gibt
dass es da alles gibt es ist eigentlich
das kann man eigentlich einfach
aufzeigen dass zeigen menschen auf oder
alle menschen die auch irgendwie mixed
race sind also übrigens transfers schon
früher war das auch ein anderes wort für
mixed race
also das ist jetzt auch eine neue
bedeutung die dem zug kommt aber das
zeigt eigentlich diese hybridität sowohl
biologisch eben scheinbar sondern aber
auch im kulturell diese arbeit will
längst gemacht von menschen die sich
also dieses dieses crossing dieser
dieser verschiedenen kontexten das
passiert eigentlich die ganze zeit für
das braucht es nicht die einführung
eines neuen begriffes oder einer neuen
also der deutlich tieferen überflüssig
aber ich meine es ist ja auch um zu
treffen nicht auch unsachgemäß also ich
glaube einfach es reduziert die
bedeutung von transgender wenn wir das
so vergleichen weil
gender eben wirklich auch diese arbeit
beinhaltet das aufzusagen
zweigeschlechtlichkeit ist ein
westliches konzept diese polarität die
es überhaupt nicht gegeben es gibt eine
riesige vielfalt und wenn translation
das gibt es eben schon diese vielfalt
ist schon aufgezeigt worden
und um sie wird dauern also es ist
passiert dauernd und es braucht von
daher gar keine
also ich meine der vergleich für mich
geht er ohnehin nur das mit tracy wenn
man jetzt sagen könnte ein schwarzer
mensch an afrikaner afrikanerin und ich
kenne solche leute der die sagt ich
fühle mich weiß wenn das bedeuten würde
sie könnte jetzt das angleichen dann
wäre ich dann wäre ich vielleicht wieder
dafür aus strategischen gründen aber das
geht eben nicht
also das heißt wir haben sozusagen ein
argument translation den begriff braucht
es nicht und es ist sozusagen rein
technisch nicht möglich und es für jahr
veränderungen vorzunehmen und das ist
auch problematisch weil es russell dann
wieder sozialisiert weil es ihr dann
wieder so tut es gibt eben zwei rassen
oder drei oder vier oder fünf und man
kann da ein rösler ich gehe mit ihnen
inhaltlich überein aber ich frage mich
ob wir dem was die die wissenschaftliche
beschäftigung mit dem thema leistet
einen guten dienst erweisen wenn wir die
begriffe immer feiner aufspalten und
sagen wir machen noch feinere noch
subtilere akademische unterscheidungen
weil der stadt wollen sie zwischen wenig
zwischen den verschiedenen lesarten von
trans und ich glaubte ich eben nicht und
ich es gibt auch ein paar sachen an die
man erinnern kann einfach um dinge
zurechtzurücken sie haben mit großer
sorgfalt amerikanische us amerikanische
beispiele gewählt ganz so als wären in
der schweiz frauen und männer komplett
gleichgestellt und es wären in der
schweiz
weiße und leute mit deutlich sichtbaren
migrationshintergrund komplett gleich
gestellt aber so ist es natürlich nicht
es gibt eine eine bilderwelt eine
zeichen eine ordnung da zeichnen die wir
uns ganz selbstverständlich bewegen in
der das geld weiß ist die bildung weiß
ist die individualität weiß ist während
armut zugehörigkeit zu einem kollektiv
zu einer masse und unbildung anders
farbiges und das sind das ist die
ordnung der zeichen in der wir uns im
jahr 2015 in der schweiz ganz
selbstverständlich bewegen oder sind sie
andere mal nein bin ich nicht anderer
meinung wir haben natürlich aber sie
haben also deswegen wieso die
amerikanischen beispiele ja der schweiz
ist interessant er glaube ich darüber
können wir gleich sprechen wie sowie
amerikanischen beispiele darüber kann
man natürlich diskutieren geht natürlich
aus von dieser debatte jetzigen lolies
halten sie natürlich auch recht dass es
im moment seien oder nicht im moment ich
glaube immer schon es ist immer
einfacher die schwierigkeiten mit einem
phänomen in anderen ländern sichtbar zu
machen und im moment finde ich es
amerika sehr interessant bezüglich der
ganzen rassendiskriminierung frage unter
anderem auch dieses buch von kwh sie
kurz vielleicht haben sie davon gehört
der brief an seinen sohn ein
intellektueller afrikaner der sagt der
schwarze körper wird zerstört und diese
ganze debatte über die hautfarbe glaube
ich ist in den usa so interessant und im
moment auch wieder so hoch gekocht weil
die geschichte der bürgerrechtsbewegung
natürlich auch eine geschichte der
hautfarbe ist aber es gibt ein argument
bei codes an dass ich herstelle erinnern
muss das sehr unangenehm ist und wo es
wirklich interessant wird darüber
nachzudenken
es gibt die demokratische zustimmung zur
gewalt gegen die farbige minderheit
er sagt das ist ein teil der
amerikanischen demokratie
gewalt gegen schwarze zu legitimieren
weil die mehrheit weiß ist das heißt
gleichheit und demokratisch und zwar
gleichheit vor dem gesetz gleich haid
bei der beim zugang zu ressourcen und
demokratische entscheidungen sind nicht
immer so kompatibel wie wir es gerne
hätten das gilt ja auch für eine reihe
von gesetzesinitiativen zur
besserstellung von der einbürgerung in
der schweiz die vom souverän regelmäßig
mit großer mehrheit abgelehnt werden ich
möchte es gar nicht mit dem chance
frauenstimmrecht und vorne das haben ja
mittlerweile erhalten
ich würde sehr gerne auch über die
schweiz aber ich würde würde es schon
noch gern noch mal zurückkommen
es geht nicht darum neue kategorien zu
schaffen eben nicht
es geht darum einen vielfalt aufzuzeigen
und und dort ist eben der punkt also
dieses dass wir ein gewisses trans bild
das sich jetzt verfestigt dass ein
privilegierter bild ist also von
menschen die sich dann die eine
geschlechts angleichung machen können
das ist legitim aber ich würde ich will
einfach festhalten es gibt da auch ganz
viele andere arbeit die damit getan wird
also transgender ist auch wird sehr mit
weiß und mit einem idealbild das dann
von männlichkeit oder von weiblichkeit
und das was sie gesagt haben dass das
von der ministerin ja auch kritisiert
wird also analog zu digital dass die
gewisse privilegien kopieren oder
gewissen problemen scheinbar
aufgewachsen sind und danach sich frauen
räume also jetzt zum beispiel trans
frauen aneignen und da muss ich eben
sagen 'das ist das hat sich aber
geändert weil feministinnen und jetzt es
frauen also biologische frauen die
feministinnen sind auch merken dass das
koalitionspartnerinnen sind weil es
genau diese menschen diese trans männer
und trans frauen weil sie beide seiten
kennen weil sie am eigenen leib erfahren
hat dass es etwas anderes ist um als
frau wahrgenommen wird oder als man
durch die straßen geht dass die
eigentlich auch gute feministische
argumente bringen und deshalb deshalb
mache das im vergleich baidu lisa für
mich kommt darauf an was sie daraus
macht
was sie für eine politik hat nicht so
sehr ob es jetzt für sie persönlich also
es ist natürlich schwieriger waren sie
es ist der anti rassismus aktivisten es
ist schwieriger als komplizin
antirassistische arbeit zu machen ja als
weise zu sagen ja ich bin weiß man muss
sich so den weißen gegenüber
rechtfertigen weil man ja irgendwie eine
verräterin ist aber auch unter schwarzen
muss man sich überlegen weshalb tue ich
das was habe ich davon
und da hatte sich ist es vielleicht ein
bisschen einfach gemacht aber ich
verurteile das nicht grundsätzlich sage
nur diese kategorie die daran wird schon
in viele art gearbeitet das aufzubrechen
ein bisschen höre ich so etwas heraus
auch wie es geht ja darum dass sie
überhaupt zb die binäre geschlechter
kategorie es gibt nur mann und frau
aufbrechen sollten es gibt einfach
unglaublich viele schattierungen genauso
wie sie auch gesagt haben es gibt auch
nicht nur schwarz oder weiß es gibt ganz
viele schattierungen und lasst uns doch
diese schattierung einfach zu lassen und
gleiche freiheiten jeweils zu sprechen
das ist ja was anliegen eigentlich der
gleichberechtigung
trotzdem frage ich mich und nicht im
kern dieser ganzen debatte das ist etwas
was mich ja was mich selber auch
umtreibt nicht die frage steht was ist
eigentlich das ziel was wollen wir
anvisieren geht es darum möglichst viel
differenz anzuerkennen und zu sagen
jeder nach seiner fasson glücklich zu
werden jeder seine identität finden und
wir versuchen möglichst jeder differenz
seine rechte zu geben oder geht es darum
möglichst die differenzen über bord zu
kippen und das gleiche zu betonen
also eher gleichheitspolitik oder eher
differenz politik was soll eigentlich
das ziel sein das ist das ist eine
riesen frage das ist ein riesen also
eine schwierigkeit die ganze
anerkennungs politik wie soll
umverteilung geschehen und ich glaube
die und im was sie sagen man muss die
menschen haben ein bedürfnis sich zu
unterscheiden und sich in
zugehörigkeiten zu verorten
und wenn man jetzt eine politik betreibt
wo man sagt ihr kommt bestimmte ressorts
aufgrund von gewissen nachteilen die das
durch die machtstrukturen die sich
ergeben
adressiert man diese personen ja auch
schon wieder als andere
also damit wird auch schon wieder eine
geschieht auch eine reproduktion also
das ist das paradox oder die
schwierigkeit daran wie macht man das
differenzen anzuerkennen und zu zulassen
und auch rechnung zu tragen und ohne
dabei wieder die menschen darauf zu
reduzieren
genau also um vielleicht ein beispiel zu
machen was mich beschäftigt facebook hat
vor ungefähr einem jahr gesagt wie
möglich in allen bei der beim
persönlichen profil zu wählen zwischen
60 geschlechtern also nicht nur frau
sondern 60 optionen da gibts sowas wie
truck da gibt es transgender
transsexuell sie müssen lachen 60
verschiedene optionen
meine frage ist ist das wirklich moderne
oder ist es nicht total konservativ war
wirklich modern wäre doch zu sagen es
gibt diese kategorie einfach nicht mehr
spielt doch keine rolle
ich frage mich ob wir uns da nicht mir
ist das ob wir uns da nicht im kreis
drehen mir ist das ein stück weit zu
sehr von den begriffen her gedacht als
könnte man über die richtigen über den
richtigen umgang mit begriffen sehr
handfesten ökonomischen und politischen
differenzen die ein bisschen weniger
schlimm machen
ich bin ein sozialhistoriker ausgebildet
und da wird man immer erst mal da wird
einem beigebracht nach zu fragen wer hat
das bezahlt was sind die ökonomischen
interessen der institutionen es gibt
natürlich ökonomische interessen von
facebook den leuten maximale identitäts
entfaltung zu ermöglichen denn
schließlich geht es darum sie für ein
werbe publikum auch optimal ein
sortierbar zu machen
ich werde das gefühl nicht los dass
viele sehr bemühte also sehr positive
versuche von den gender start ist zum
beispiel erst mal zu nichts anderem
führen als zu hoch spezialisierten
sprachspielen die dann an philosophische
nicht letztendlich nicht lösbare
grundsatz probleme rühren was bedeutet
was macht die sprache mit uns was können
wir von der sprache erwarten die das
reden über hautfarben ist normalerweise
und über identität ist normalerweise ein
reden darüber welche zu welchen
ressourcen wer zugang hat und die
allermeisten und die allerwichtigsten
ressourcen zu denen wir zugang haben
ökonomische wie politische haben mit
unserer individualität nichts zu tun
sondern dass die kriegen wir weil wir
zum beispiel bürgerinnen oder bürger
eines wohlhabenden landes sind oder weil
wir eine ganz bestimmte anerkannte
berufsausbildung gemacht haben das hat
mit unseren individualitäten oder weil
wir ein problem mann oder eine frau sind
gar nichts zu tun
das heißt das reden über die begriffe
neigt dazu das reden über sehr handfeste
ökonomische ungleichheiten immer wie in
den hintergrund zurück darf ich noch
noch einen schritt zu spitzen und sich
fragen ob sie dem zustimmen würden wenn
sie sagen in einer vollkommen
gleichberechtigten gesellschaft wäre
hautfarbe nicht mehr wichtiges kategorie
ich nehme es an weil man das reden über
hautfarben ist auch ein reden über
vergnügen an andersheit und ich glaube
es gibt wenig themen historisch die so
erotisch aufgeladen sind die hautfarben
dass wenn sie mir mich glauben schauen
sie sich einen beliebigen katalog eine
schweizer ferien anbieters an die vielen
interessanten schönen jungen menschen
mit verschiedenen hautfarben die man da
sehen kann
das heißt es geht
es geht gar nicht wieso muss ich immer
vom ideal ausgehen kann ich nicht von
der etwas schmutzigen unordentlichen
extrem ungleich verteilten wirklichkeit
ausgehen wie ich sie vor mir habe das
heißt von den zeichen für hautfarben die
in der gegenwart kursieren wenn ich mir
zum beispiel werbeplakate anschaue wer
kriegt auf welchem werbe plakat welche
hautfarben das hat sich nämlich in der
schweiz in den letzten 20 jahren
ziemlich geändert
sie verstehen was ich meine das heißt
ich würde viel er ja die haben meine
frage nicht mehr am tatort oder frage
ich verantworten kann weil es auf diese
fragen glaube ich auch keine angst gibt
ein sie ihre alte mehr frauen seien in
de es wäre doch interessant sich zu
überlegen brauchen wir diese
zuschreibungen nicht eben gerade gefiel
diese kategorisierungen wer ist man wer
ist frau er ist schwarz wie ist weiß
nicht auch deswegen dass er jetzt mit
foucault gesprochen ein stück weit
unsere machtverhältnisse zementieren
wollen
und wenn es diese machtverhältnisse
nicht mehr gäbe das auch kann man auch
judith butler aus beispiel nehmen dann
würden auch diese differenzen stärker
angegeben sie würden zumindest nicht
mehr so eine starke rolle spielen und
sieht man so was sie zu facebook gesagt
haben ich finde also diese
kategorisierung dann geht es plötzlich
60 jahre da bin ich schon auch ihre
meinung das ist das ist eine sackgasse
das ist auch eine neoliberale vision die
arbeit am selbst sind alle nur noch
damit beschäftigt mit mit der eigenen
enthüllung und also diese ganze
bekenntnis kultur die die total
entpolitisieren wirkt weil wir trotzdem
in beziehungen leben
das kam ja nicht ausklammern aber
gleichzeitig muss ich schon sagen dass
mit der sprache also sprache ist
wirkmächtig das ist gerade mit
rassistischen mit rassistischen
sprachgebrauch dass das das tat einfach
eine wirkung also ich finde man kann
nicht einfach sagen ja dabei denn es
geht um um sprachspiele klar es gibt
eine gewisse theoretische diskurse die
nicht so einfach jetzt auch übersetzbar
sind hier aber da da würde ich einfach
sagen muss man schon vorsichtig sein
aber was die lösung ist dass diese ganze
frage von ökonomischen
ressourcenverteilung
das ist ein riesen problem weil wir in
machtstrukturen leben die die einfach
sehr schwer zu unterwandern sinn weil
macht eben auch sehr cool er ist weil
wir als subjekte angerufen werden eben
weil wir dann die angebot also die eth
macht des zirkus' leer
wir sind alle teil von von wie macht
produziert wird also schwarz geht es
nicht ohne weiß weiß gibt es nicht ohne
schwarz also heimat gibt es nicht ohne
ausnahme genau und und was man damit
dann damit macht also wenn man sagen wir
als als fremd bildeten aufgerufen wäre
es gibt dann auch die tendenz der selbst
ex aktivierung um um lesbar zu sein in
einem bestimmten kontext nimmt man auch
eine gewisse position an die immer an
einen heran geht auch ein wir alle auch
frauen die selber stereotypen von frauen
reproduzieren zum beispiel machen die an
dieser stelle vielleicht mal ein schnitt
weg von diesem politischen diskurs zu
diesen stereotypen mit stereotypen wird
ja auch gern gespielt sie dienen auch
immer wieder dazu witze zu machen
persiflagen zu machen es gibt ein
wunderbares beispiel den französischen
vielen müsse bloß seine töchter der
finden ist von philippe bozon er hat es
in den schweizer kinos im letzten jahr
auch seele gefühl für viele lacher
gesorgt da geht es um einen franzosen
einen gaullisten der vier töchter hat
drei davon sind bereits mit ausländern
verheiratet zu seinen großen leidwesen
finde ich schaue sie räkeln sie nicht
mit ausländern gehalten und haben recht
es sind aber keine zusagen für ihn sind
kein liberalen sogar anzurufen genau
danke für die korrektur da haben sie
recht
jetzt ist die vierte tochter daran ihren
partner den eltern vorzustellen
sie verschweigt beim vorstellen dieses
verlobten dass er schwarz ist und wir
sehen in diesen ausschnitt reaktion der
eltern die beiden linke tisch ist das
ist das erfahre das ist nicht der fahrer
gehört das ist ja ja sag mal hast du ihm
gesagt dass ich schwarz bin
sie kommen so komisch dass das nicht
vergisst du aber das vergisst man doch
nicht dein vater tochter schlag
das ist mein schatz du hättest mich vor
wagen können dass sie weiß sind aber
muss lachen warum muss man machen
wir lachten über normalerweise lachen
wir über das was bedrohlich ist und sich
dann auflöst oder nicht möglicherweise
was ich hier bedrohlich und löst sich
auf oder finden sie die szene gar nicht
lustig wieso ich musste richtig lachen
als ich zum ersten mal gesehen habe ich
fand es interessant die strategie die
der junge mann anwendet und quasi der
versuch dieser umkehrung und ich finde
aber die und die eltern es funktioniert
nicht die eltern lachen ja nicht also
erst als dann das geht nun weiter als
die verlobte seite hat dass er als
schauspieler das war ein witz und dann
irgendwie so ein komisches künstliches
lachen haben sie es eigentlich überhaupt
nicht gecheckt weil die definitionsmacht
dessen was anders ist und was eben
unlackiert neutral ist die ist ja bei
ihnen dies ja auf ihrer seite
und wenn sie ihren verlobten vorstellt
und der heißt charles er ist katholisch
als schauspieler dann denken sie nicht
daran dass er auch schwarz sein könnte
genau sie sind extrem erlöst dass dieser
mann eben katholisch ist und franzose
dass er es noch schauer heißt und
rechnet mit einem weißen aber die szene
ist ja eigentlich deswegen komisch weil
der verlobte der schau einen witz macht
insofern dass er sagt letzten aussagen
können dass seine eltern weiß sind also
dass ich ja bricht ja sozusagen das
stereotyp in die andere richtung
deswegen erachten wir wahrscheinlich
diese sorte schon witz auch aus
legitimen nicht als rassistisch im sinne
von nicht erlaubt also ich überlegen
jetzt gerade umgekehrt wird es ja gar
nicht funktionieren also besser meine
ich ist es so klar wo die macht ist zu
kennzeichnen und zu definieren
was was ist das eigene und was ist das
andere
und ich meine wenn ich jetzt ein
bisschen vor greifen darf in dem film
schlussendlich werden ja diese rassen
grenzen und ich sage immer rus weil ich
empfinde das ist mir als hautfarbe
werden die über überschritten
aber es beruht sehr stark darauf dass
eben gewisse andere parameter stimmen
also diese dieser schale kommt aus gutem
haus also die klasse ist dann ähnlich
auch alle anderen söhne bzw
viele söhne denn auch aus gutem haus
dann ist das ganze sehr heterosexuelle
verheiratet die die ehe in die brüche
gehen sind dann auch wieder gerettet
also man kann sich über andere kategorie
oder auch gender ist ganz klar all diese
frauen sind wahnsinnig schön haben lange
wallende haare die männer entsprechend
auch ein gewissen stereotyp also dass
über diese diese anderen kategorien die
die beiden väter die können sich am
schluss richtig verbrüdern bei der
schwarze vater der wahrheit kolonial
soldat kennt die französische kultur
also er macht eigentlich die
anpassungsleistung und und dadurch sind
sie schlussendlich dann doch ist dann
ist dann alles gute
aber der film spielt ja dauernd mit
stereotypen und viele witze rassistische
witze sind ja immer an der grenze dessen
was geht es gibt momente wie zb finden
wir lustig es gibt witze da finden wir
sind geschmacklos im moment tobt eine
debatte im internet darüber ob es
legitim ist einem clean kostüm zu tragen
an halloween also dieses kleid das kate
lynch einer auf den man iti verkäufer
trägt gibt es jetzt als kostüm zu kaufen
und männerstimmen sich das über mit
perücke und gehen so zum zu halloween
party zur nächsten
und da stellt sich die frage darf man
das darf man das
ich finde die ganze ich gehe mal ich
finde dass ich finde dass gemessen
[Musik]
das ist ein mediales spiegelkabinett
hier geht es nicht um die veränderung
von irgendwas
hier geht es um das austauschen von
stereotypen um über stereotypen zu reden
mit mit mit den wirklichen
entscheidungen und zwar entscheidungen
zwischen dingen die man sich nicht
aussuchen kann hat das doch gar nichts
zu tun
also dann würden sie sagen es gibt auch
keine grenze dessen was man darf im
spiel mit stereotypen
früher gab es die sogenannten sich im
kinder auf die sogenannten ne geile da
hat man sich plaques facing mäßig
geschminkt man hat sich kraushaar
perücken aufgesetzt und ging als
negation casting waren sie da auch um
kers sie haben aber jetzt gerade die
ebene gewechselt sie haben nämlich von
einem von der medienaufmerksamkeit für
ein ganz spezifisches amerikanisches
problem gewechselt zu einem zu einer
veränderung im umgang mit schwarzer haut
und das mohrenkopf glaube ich jetzt auch
an das heißt offiziell das heißt eine
etwas was mit der mit dem eigenen alltag
zu tun hat habe ich die ebene gewechselt
sind die fälle nicht ähnlich ich finde
es schon ich bin schon dass man das
zusammen denken darf also und ich finde
letztlich es kommt immer darauf an wozu
es dient also manchmal haben ja also
jetzt dass dieses beispiel mit dem einem
caitlin wozu es führt manchmal geht es
auch sehr contra intuitive wirkung was
was dann daraus wird dass das weiß man
also grundsätzlich würde ich auch sagen
das kommt so es gibt zu diese diese
neoliberale logik die dahinter ist ja
dass man sich eben wählen kann und dass
das wird mir das stimmt eben hat leider
nicht gleichzeitig
die das spiel also wenn es irgendetwas
gibt was universell ist würde ich jetzt
einfach mal behaupten ist es schon die
lust daran sich zu verwandeln um es um
zur transformation wandelbarkeit und und
sich eben nicht festlegen zu müssen und
und bälle jeder art das ist natürlich
also ich denke jetzt in ghana gibt es
auch ganz viele tracking das wird nicht
so genannt aber dass das gibt es schon
lange dass das dann männer sich als
frauen verkleiden und umgekehrt ja also
grundsätzlich aber ich finde bei eben
schon immer mit race und also ebene
wechsel ich finde schon die frage
man muss es halt historisieren ja und
bei rasse gibt es einfach eine
geschichte die so zentral ist und so
einschneidend die das weiße subjekt
geprägt hat die also jetzt mal ganz
abgesehen von all den menschen die über
den atlantik und und auch nicht nur
diese seite auch über den pazifik also
die geschichte von sklaverei von leuten
die sich dann ganz neu erfinden musste
mussten und diese geschichte ist eben
auch hier auch in der schweiz
wir können uns da nicht draußen und ich
glaube dort ist der punkt wo ich finde
müssen wir schon ein bisschen
differenzieren weil es da so überhaupt
gar keine symmetrie gibt eben wir haben
das gesehene beispiel diese umkehrung
funktioniert nicht und deshalb würde ich
jetzt sagen nein das geht nicht
also außer man könnte das umgekehrte
auch machen und sich daran erfreuen sich
ein reiches kostüm kaufen so zu sagen
und ich weiß anmalen und das dann also
ich glaube dort dort ist der knackpunkt
auch sie haben vorhin nur in einem
kleinen aufwasch gesagt identität wir
wollen die wechseln wir wissen aber das
geht nicht wir können die nicht einfach
frei wählen sprechen wir zum schluss
über diese identitätsfrage wie frei sind
wir denn in der wahl der identität haben
ja schon zu erkennen gegeben
herr krömer sie finden diesen begriff
schwierig das ist ein klebstoff für sie
ich glaube das ist dass man extrem viel
gewinnt wenn man statt identität
identifizierung sagt damit klar ist dass
das etwas ist was leute tun
das ist nicht etwas was man hat
sondern das ist etwas was gemacht wird
und ganz viele formeln identisch
identität
das schweizer fernsehen sagt von sich
selbst es ist für es ist
identitätsstiftend es ist gleichzeitig
heimat und fenster zur welt
das bedeutet nichts
in dem moment wo die identifizierung
sorgen ist das nichts was immer schon da
ist auf eine ganz komische art und weise
ist ja identität etwas wovon offenbar
immer zu wenig da ist es muss
hergestellt werden es muss gestiftet
werden
und ganz viele und sehr viele von diesen
problemen mit der sprache tauchen ja
dadurch auf dass jemand sagt ich spreche
jetzt im namen eines kollektivs ich
spreche jetzt im namen aller aufrechten
schweizerinnen frauenmangel oder ich
spreche jetzt im namen der unterdrückten
das sind ja jeweils rollenspiele die
sich nicht im luftleeren raum abspielen
ganz anders ist es in der
ausländerbehörde oder im schalter oder
bei den flüchtlingen die haben die sind
diesen tatsächlich individualisiert und
müssen jeweils unter allen tricks die
ihnen zur verfügung stehen versuchen wo
hinzukommen
das heißt wenn sie wenn es ihnen darum
geht wie viel identität haben wir dann
reden wir doch bitte über konkrete
beispiele und mit ein bisschen weniger
wir über dieses wir wir müssen das macht
mich immer ganz nervös
das muss erst mal gar nix ich glaube ich
sprechen wir über sie sprechen wie
beispielsweise über über ihr bild in
ihrem neuesten buch ich plakate da geht
es auch sehr stark um identität oder
identifikation und gesicht da gibt es
ein bild von ihnen dass ich ihr
pressebild das hat ihre tochter gewalt
sich sechs jahre alt haben sie mir
gesagt damit identifizieren sie sich mit
diesem bild oder hat dieses bild gar
nichts zu tun mit dem zuschuss
für meine tochter und warum wählen sie
das als bild von ihnen weil der großteil
des buches davon handelt dass man auf
fotos und wie auf gemalten bildern keine
person erkennt sondern erst mal ein bild
diese bilder funktionieren als bilder
und nicht als die identität einer person
auch wenn sie sozusagen als identitäts
verwendet werden als miniatur kleine
vervielfältigte optimierte miniatur
version von etwas davon handelt das buch
aber das bin natürlich dass bin
natürlich nicht ich sondern mir schien
es komisch für ein buch das ein stück
weit auch eine kritik an dem normalen
umgang mit fotos ist und ein versuch
darüber anders nach darüber anders
nachzudenken dann ein ganz normales
autoren foto wie immer auf den
rückwärtigen umgang umschlag des buches
zu kleben
das zeichnen von sich selber das
gezeichnet werden nicht auch ein
interessantes moment und rachel usa
selber hat von sich gesagt hätte sich
immer schon als kind schwarz gezeichnet
darf ich sie fragen frau dankbar
wie haben sie sich auf kind gezeichnet
mit einem großen korb von großen augen
ich habe so ein bild im kopf
ich habe mich browne gezeichnet meine
eltern haben sehr uns versucht zu
vermitteln seid stolz darauf dass sie an
schwarzen einen weißen elternteil habt
und so kam es dann auch auf den
zeichnungen da gab es den weißen
farbstiften schwarzen und den braunen
und das war dann meine kategorisierung
die vorgenommen habe und ich bin auch
zum teil in grane aufgewachsen wo eben
eine andere race politik noch
funktioniert wurde dieses dazwischen
dieses mixed race eben eine kategorie
ist also ich habe mich erst in der
schweiz dann als schwarz zu
identifizieren begonnen als auch als
politisch schwarz ich danke ganz
herzlich in beiden für dieses gespräch
dankeschön
ganz neu können wir uns also nicht mehr
finden wenn wir sind abhängig von den
zeiten in denen wir leben und von den
geschichten die unsere biografie
ausmacht
das gilt nicht nur für jeden einzelnen
von uns sondern auch für gesellschaften
viele staaten ringen gegenwärtig mit
ihrer nationalen identität und allzu
schnell überlassen sie diese suche
populisten von rechts oder links
das ist gefährlich sagt der historiker
fritz stern mit ihm spreche ich nächste
woche
ich freue mich wenn sie wieder dabei
sind jetzt aber erst einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]